[Music]
the world created a record 2.2 billion
tons of waste in 2021
by 2050
that figure may nearly double the world
is in short not dealing well with its
waste problem
so what can consumers
governments and companies do
to make the world less rubbish
turning pollutions into a life-saving
solution and could a zero-waste planet
become a reality
[Music]
this man helped build wards for covert
19 patients in 2021
what's unusual is that arthur huang
built them out of trash
here we are turning a local waste from
recycled aluminium recycle polypropylene
recycled pet from the medical waste
system and we're turning that into a
medical war system for the pandemic
instead of bricks and cement the walls
of these modular wards were put together
from recycled materials what we have
created is a series of lego blocks and
once you click together the building can
be built within 24 hours arthur is the
inventive engineer behind mini whiz he
says his company is showing that it's
possible to make money out of solving
the world's waste problem
by turning local trash
into cash
you want to source your material as
close to where the building construction
is happening so that right away you save
just on managing your supply chain
within the close proximity
miniwiz focuses on buildings
because not only is construction the
most material intensive industry in the
world consuming 42 billion tons of
resources annually
it also produces about one third of all
global waste
why we focus on building is because
there is a scale match between trash how
much trash we produce and how much
material we use in buildings
arthur believes that one of the keys to
reducing global waste is upcycling
creating additional value out of waste
products
so a simple one that everyone talked
about is upcycling of pet bottles into
yarns
into your jerseys into the shirt for
example into my shoes for example why is
that called upcycling it's because the
inherent value of a packaging
is
less than the second life it produces
but upcycling will only be embraced
globally if more examples like this can
be found
ones that make business as well as
environmental sense
to show the potential of upcycling mini
wizard's latest project turned an old
bank into new offices
everything you see from the ceiling made
from recycled polyester and recycled
linen fiber all the way to the brick
made from recycled semiconductor casing
in the production process all the way to
the sofa pillows made from recycled
polyester which is from a plastic bottle
even the old neckties of the bankers
were up-cycled into artwork
we're using our old type on touching
securities in the
document case and i think this is a left
over our seating panels yeah it looks
like a chinese painting actually yeah
but it's actually using a machine just
like doing this
arthur argues that traditional recycling
is a waste of time
because it demands resources doesn't add
value
and usually just delays the material
ending up in waste
i want to recycle a plastic bottle a
single use back into a single use that
to me is called down cycling but some
experts caution against placing too much
faith in recycling or upcycling
i think in terms of looking at how we
manage waste we need to remove this idea
of a silver bullet altogether
there is no single technical solution
that is going to fix everything
there is a trend globally that we are
producing too much waste
in contrast to how quickly we are
managing it and finding alternative
methods and uses for our waste
one of the challenges is that
comparatively little waste ends up being
recycled
currently 37
of solid waste goes to landfill
worldwide 33
to open dumps 11 to incinerators all
told only 14 of municipal solid waste is
recycled globally
improving this will depend on expanding
what's known as the circular economy
based on the principle of reduce reuse
recycle
the traditional linear economy is built
on the premise of take make dispose
and it's this approach which still
dominates the world
only 8.6
of the global economy is circular
and expanding it will require the rest
of the world to follow the surprising
lead
of a country once known as garbage
island
taiwan is now the golden child globally
in terms of circular economy and waste
management
here in taiwan they've even built a
monument to recycling this cultural
space known as the eco arc pavilion
has become a symbol of how to bin
throwaway culture the taiwanese people
gave 1.5 million plastic bottles to help
build it
so how did taiwan managed to get from
this
this island of 20 million people is
literally overflowing with rubbish to
this
the story starts in the 1990s when
taiwan faced a familiar problem
the richer it got the more stuff it
chucked away like much of asia taiwan
experienced a really booming economy and
with that came more spending more buying
of products
improvements to quality of life but also
increases in waste
already 95 of its 200 landfill sites are
full
[Music]
since then taiwan's government has used
planning and data to create one of the
most advanced integrated waste
management systems in the developed
world
by law large companies accounting for 80
percent of industrial waste have to log
and report the materials they use and
the waste they generate
this is novel in that it's now a web
application you and i can look at this
database and see a comprehensive flow of
materials that includes advanced
modeling to show us graphics
of different resources and different
industries
there are government incentives for
companies to reduce waste
and penalties if they don't
and the buck doesn't stop there
are not allowed to let their trash touch
the street
and you can even be paid for reporting
those who mess with the law
you can get a reward for
ratting out your neighbor for doing bad
environmental behaviors
taiwan has become a global poster child
for recycling
recovering 55 of rubbish collected from
households
by contrast america recycles 35
and russia just five to seven percent
but taiwan's clean streets do also hide
something of a dirty secret virtually
all the rubbish which is not recycled is
incinerated
and while taiwan's incinerators are
comparatively clean
they still dump carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere one of the very interesting
facts about taiwan is it has the highest
density of trash burning plant we have
zero landfill policies so yes taiwan
become not a trash island but because
now we're just pumping trash into the
air
which countries create the majority of
the world's waste
and it's the sheer volume that
encourages the use of incineration
in places like edmonton in north london
we treat about a quarter of london's
waste
it's around 500 000 tons a year 10 000
tons a week if you think about that that
fifty thousand double decker buckets
worth of waste per year coming to this
facility from the people of north london
and for some who work in waste
management
sites such as this are a reminder that
consuming less is central to reducing
global waste the first time i saw this i
wanted to reduce my impact and the
amount of waste i was coming into here
the sheer volume of waste and a witness
to being burned in his professional life
persuaded him to change his personal one
completely
i had a i could say like a light bulb
moment i saw the sheer quantity of waste
taking a data-led approach to his
consumption habits he's embraced what's
called the zero waste movement
and this is the end product
so this is the entire waste that i
produce in one month in in a jar
the top
bottle wine top tops you can't recycle
that
over a year the average london house
produces
536 kilograms of waste
by reducing his consumption
and produced just 5.7 kilos per year
that's 99 less than average
limiting the amount of waste that i was
putting out
and making it visible to me that was
actually quite important making waste
visible
it makes you realize how much more waste
you produce and i went quite the extra
mile to go to that point
zero waste remains a niche movement
globally
but there are encouraging signs that
consumers are grasping the need to
consume less
a report found that 6 out of 10 people
across 28 rich countries
would be willing to change their
shopping habits to reduce environmental
impact
okay thank you
how are you yes thank you are you okay
and ethical zero waste shops offering
refills reflect this trend we helped in
a year our customers reduce about 10 000
plastic containers
but reducing the world's waste will also
require new technologies to improve the
recovery of valuable materials from
their waste stream
and to improve their repurposing for the
benefit of consumers
back in taiwan arthur has designed this
mobile trash press
it uses artificial intelligence to
separate different materials
which can be shredded and later used to
make new products
for example the mask it has a specific
material it has a material property is
being recorded by the ai machine
through this transpressor process you
can turn a mask into a phone charger
with no secondary pollution
and
it become a wireless charger
it's not just the environmental
conscience of consumers which will be
needed to expand the circular economy
this new economy will need to create
everyday products which consumers think
of as first choice
rather than second hand
the chair i'm sitting in is made from
all jeans yeah
you don't want to make
a sustainable or circular economy a
theoretical topic you want that to be an
everyday topic
a lifestyle decision
you wear sunglasses this is made from
rice husk and this is also made from
recycled cigarette
recycling upcycling is always a bit it
can be a bit enough but when when you
turn something
like this
and it's it makes it a lot more
interesting even in taiwan many
consumers are yet to be convinced by the
circular economy
a more sustainable future can be built
by finding better and more integrated
ways to manage waste across the world
but there is work to do before this
global mess is cleaned up
in terms of
really changing how society views
making producing and managing waste
how we view
products and the waste that they create
i think those changes are generational
thanks for watching i'm tom standage
deputy editor of the economist if you'd
like to find out more about a zero waste
world please click on the link and don't
forget to subscribe
you